THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY NINTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS HEREBY
CALLED ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED
ON AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDINGS
BEING MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS AND IS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC A TENTATIVE TERMS WERE
MASK AT ALL TIMES AND COMPLY
WITH GUIDANCE ON PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. ATTENDEES MUST ALSO
REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING. PHYLICIA THESE
RULES WERE SUBJECTED INDIVIDUAL
TO REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS- MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM THEN AT FLORA GIPSON
HERE LEE YEAH LEVINE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS FROM US
RUBIO YOU PUT OFF HERE. NO
QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM. NOTE
THAT TODAY FOR ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB THREE THREE EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST ALL WE
WILL CONDUCT A HEARING THE CALL
IN NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO AGAIN
FOR AB THREE THREE EIGHT ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT THE CALL IN NUMBER
IS. 877-692-8957 WITH AN ACCESS
CODE OF. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO OH TWO. OF YOU CAN
ALSO FIND HIS NUMBERS ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
THE TV SCREEN. WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA IS ALMOST LIKE
SENATE CHEN. MOVE OVER SERVICE
ANIMALS GIPSON- MISTER SERVICE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY I COOLEY
AYE CUNNINGHAM THEN AT FLORA
GIPSON. GIPSON HIGHLY LI HI
LEVINE HI LEVINE HI MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MATHIS AYE RAMOS RAMOS
OUR RUBIO RUBIO HIVE YOU PUT
WHAT YOU COULD WELL HI MOTION
PASSES TO MOTIONS PASSED WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB 338% OF OUR RAMOS-
MISTER ROBERTS AND MISTER
MATHIS I. ADVISOR GROUP FORTY
AM AND. MAYBE AGAIN. RIGHT.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT AB THREE THREE EIGHT-
THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION THE
SECOND- WITH ME TODAY WILL BE A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS ONE THE
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHORS WITH ME ON
THIS BILL BUT AS YOU CAN SEE-
HERE FROM THE CUT OUT THAT'S
WITH US TODAY IS A TRUE
FACTUAL- DEPICTION OF THEM
MIWOK INNOCENT PEOPLE FROM THIS
AREA ITSELF. I WANT TO THANK
YOU- FOR BRINGING BEING ABLE TO
PRESENT THIS BILL AND BRING IN
A MEASURE FORWARD- THE VOICE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE- TO
AN ISSUE OF MISTREATMENT AND
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF A HORDE
PASSED THE BROADER TRUSTEES IN
GENOCIDE TO CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE. VERY LITTLE OF
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
SLAVERY DURING THE MISSION
PERIOD IS CAPTURED IN OUR
HISTORY BOOKS. SPANISH FRIARS
AND MILITARY SUB DUDE AND
ENSLAVE CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE
AMERICANS. TO FORCED LABORS AND
DISPLACED FAMILY MEMBERS IN
THEIR QUEST TO COLONIZE THE
ALREADY INHABITED CALIFORNIA. A
MENTALITY THAT CARRIED FORWARD
TO THE STATE'S EARLIEST LEADERS
WITH THE FIRST GOVERNOR OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SETTING OUT
PAID BOUNTIES TO FORMALISMS AND
AIDED BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WHO EMBARKED ON A DELIBERATE
POLICY OF GENOCIDE AS DEFINED.
BY POST HOLOCAUST HUMAN RIGHTS
TRIBUNALS ONE PANEL SET UP
SERVICES THAT CONSTANT REMINDER
THAT THAT ERA OF VIEWING THE
CALIFORNIA INDIANS AS LESS THAN
HUMAN. SOME ARGUE THAT SERRA
SHOULD NOT BE JUDGED BY TODAY'S
VALUES YET AS EARLY AS FIFTEEN
THIRTY SPANISH KING CARLOS SAID
I FOR BED SLAVERY DO TO THE
TREATMENTS TREATMENT OF INDIANS.
THE FRENCH NAVY CAPTAIN ONE
FRANCIS TO GALLOP UPON ARRIVING
IN MONTEREY BAY IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY SIX WAS APPALLED BY THE
MISSIONARIES ABUSE OF NATIVE
AMERICANS RIDING CORPORAL
PUNISHMENT IS INFLICTED ON THE
INDIANS OF BOTH SEXES WHO
NEGLECT THE EXERCISE OF PITY
AND MANY SINS WHICH IN EUROPE
ARE LEFT TO DIVIDE JUSTICES ARE
HERE PUNISHED BY IRONS AND
STOCKS. AND IT CONTINUES IT
CONTINUES IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
POPE FRANCIS HIMSELF APOLOGIZED
FOR THE MANY GRAVE SINS
COMMITTED AGAINST THE NATIVE
PEOPLE OF AMERICA. AND ASK FOR
FORGIVENESS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
ASK FOR FORGIVENESS IN IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE SEE IN THE
STATUE OF ONE PANEL CENTER COME
DOWN ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS IN
BETWEEN ALL THAT HISTORY THE
ENGAGEMENT OF THE INDIAN PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
NOT BEEN DONE YET FOR OVER
FIFTY YEARS SERRA STATUE HAS
STOOD ON THE CAPITOL PARK. AS A
CONSTANT REMINDER TO THE NATIVE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA OF THE
ATROCITIES COMMITTED AGAINST
THEM AND THE HORRID TREATMENT
INFLICTED UPON HIM DURING THE
SO CALLED COLONIZATION PERIOD
THIS BILL WILL PAVE THE WAY FOR
THE VOICE OF THOSE WHO WERE
OPPRESSED ENSLAVED AND FORCED
TO LABOR TO BUILD THE MISSIONS
TO ONCE AND FOR ALL HAVE A
VOICE. A VOICE THAT WILL TELL
OF FACTUAL ACCOUNT OF HISTORY
THAT HAS NOT BEEN TOLD ON A
LEVEL THAT WOULD GIVE A
BALANCED APPROACH TO THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A VOICE
THAT HAS BEEN A LONG TIME
COMING AND NOW IS A CHANCE TO
HAVE THAT VOICE BE HEARD. THIS
BILL WILL BRING IN A NEW ERA.
ONE WHERE CALIFORNIA'S ELECTED
OFFICIALS TAKE ACTION TO
CORRECT THE WRONGS OF THE PAST.
AND TO RECOGNIZE THE IMMENSE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICANS HAVE MADE TO
THIS GREAT STATE. AND THE
IMMENSE SACRIFICES THAT CAME
ALONG WITH IT. AB THREE THREE
EIGHT WELL AUTHORIZED THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A LONG OVERDUE
MONUMENT TO THE TRIBES WHO
CONTINUE TO CALL THIS PLACE%
HOME HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA IT WILL BRING A LONG
OVERDUE END TO THE MEMORIZATION
OF A MAN WHO SET FORTH THE
MENTALITY OF TREATING
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE. AS
LESS THAN HUMAN. BY THE ALL.
THE CONTINUED. OF THE FATHER
SERWIS IN THE CAP PARK IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT TO. WITH ME
TODAY HELLO WITH MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MATT. ALL CHAIRMAN HEY
SUE STRANGLE OF WILTON
RANCHERIA AND CHAIRWOMAN REGINA
KUMAR- SHINGLE SPRINGS
RANCHERIA. MISTER MATHIS WHO
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU A
SLIMMER RAMOS THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. AS WE ALL
KNOW THIS STATUS CHANGED. IN
RECENT YEARS SINCE THE STATURE
FATHER SIR WAS A RECORD HERE AT
THE STATE CAPITOL. WE ALL LIVE
IN A NEW ERA. AND IT'S DUE TIME
THAT WE CHOOSE WHO WE AS A
STATE. CELEBRATE BASED ON OUR
CURRENT VALUES. RATHER THAN
THOSE OF THE MISGUIDED VALUES
OF THE PAST. THIS BILL WILL
ACCOMPLISH JUST THAT AND I AM
PROUD TO STAND WITH MY FRIEND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AND THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY. THE
CALL FOR A NEW MONUMENT. FOR A
NEW MODERN CALIFORNIA. IS ONLY
RIGHT THAT WE HONOR. THESE
HORRIBLE TRAGIC LOSSES OF OUR
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY. WE
HAVE COME TO A TIME WHERE THIS
BODY MUST DECIDE WHAT WE TRULY
STAND FOR. WE TALK ABOUT SOCIAL
EQUALITY ABOUT HEALING PAST
WOUNDS. ABOUT ENDING INJUSTICES.
BUT IS ONLY TALK IF OUR ACTIONS
AND OUR VOTES DO NOT REFLECT
THESE VALUES WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT. MEMBERS. WE MUST ALL
MAKE THE ATROCITIES OF OUR PAST
AND WE MUST MOVE FORWARD. AND
EMBRACE OUR HISTORY A STARK IS
A MAYBE AT TIMES. AND COME
TOGETHER AS A BODY. IN DO THE
RIGHT THING. CHAIR MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND YOUR AYE VOTES TODAY THANK
YOU- THANK YOU SUMMER MATHIS.
AT THIS TIME WE WILL NOW TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM WITNESSES SIMPLE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE
EIGHT- OPERATOR CAN YOU.
ACCOMMODATE CHAIRMAN TRIANGLE.
YES SO YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE PLACE
YOU BACKING Q. AGAIN TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIRS- GIVEN THEIR LINE
NUMBERS THANK YOU. MR TRIANGLE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK YOUR
LINE IS OPEN SO. JUST PLEASE ON
MUTE YOURSELF BEFORE WE GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU.
KEVIN COLLEY AT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COULD YOU COULD LOOK
UP THE JOKES AS MUCH AS A POKER
I KNOW YEAH SET THESE TWO
TRIANGLE I AM THE TERMINAL WILL
RANCHERIA I'M HONORED TO BE
HERE TODAY AND HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JAMES RAMOS AND THE FIVE
SPONSORING TRIBES. I'M ALSO
HONORED TO TESTIFY TODAY IN
STRONG. SUPPORT IS VERY
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. MY AND
DID CHAIRED PAPA THE AND SECTOR
COUNTY REGION. MY ANCESTORS
INHABITED THE LAND THAT WORK
LOCATED ALONG THE PATH THE
MASSIVE DEATH AND DESTRUCTION
OF CALIFORNIA INDIANS. CALLED
BY THE SPANISH MISSIONARY
SYSTEM. THE MEXICAN AND
AMERICAN MILITARY INCURSIONS
DISEASE THE BRUTALITY AND
TORTURE THAT RESULTS FROM
SLAVERY AS WELL TO BUY THE
COMPANY MY TO GET SETTLED. THEY
SIT HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY WANT
TO BE CLEAR IT'S ABOUT MORE
THAN ONE ABOUT A SET OF. AS
IMPORTANT AS IT IS AB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT IS JUST ONE STEP
TOWARDS DOING THE RIGHT THING
FOR THE INDIGENOUS ME WALK AND
LISTEN I'M PEOPLE OF THE
SACRAMENTO REGION. BUT ABOUT US
THERE WAS NOT A GOOD MAN.
ALTHOUGH THE INTENTIONS WERE
DEBATED WE GOOD THE MEANS BY
WHICH YOU PURSUED HIS GOAL OF
SAVING INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
ELIMINATE ALL ARGUMENTS THAT HE
WAS A GOOD MAN. SOME MAY ARGUE
THAT ONE OF BETTER SERVICE
WORKERS GOT SENT. FOR MY PEOPLE
WHO LIFTED THE ENSLAVEMENT AND
THE BRUTAL ATROCITIES OF THIS
MAN. OUR VIEW IS QUITE THE
CONTRARY AND INDISPUTABLE. GOOD
MEN DO NOT AUTHORIZE THE
BRUTALIZATION OF MEN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN AN ATTEMPT TO PURIFY
THEIR BODIES OF STAN AND THEIR
WAY OF LIFE. GOOD MEN DO NOT
BUILD THE SYSTEM BY WHICH
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE WERE RIPPED
AWAY FROM THEIR HOMES AND
FORCED INTO A HARSH LABOR FOR A
REASON THAT SAW THE MESS OF
HUMAN. TRUTH BE TOLD THE ENTIRE
NARRATIVE ABOUT ONE ABOUT A
SERAPH AND IS WORKING AS A
PUBLIC INSTRUMENT. IS ABOUT A
MUCH LARGER SYSTEM OF
OPPRESSION THAT STOP TO
DECIMATE CALIFORNIA'S
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS SYSTEM IS
WITHOUT A DOUBT A CHAPTER IN
THE STATE'S HISTORY THAT NEEDS
TELLING. THOSE WISHING TO
REMOVE SERRA'S NAME AND LIKE
THIS FROM PUBLIC I DO NOT WISH
TO RE WRITE HISTORY OR UNDO
WHAT WAS DONE IN THE PAST.
INSTEAD THOSE SUCH AS MYSELF
AND MY PEOPLE SEE YOU SEE WHAT
ABOUT A SERRA AS A SYMBOL OF
UNTRUTHFUL HISTORY. THAT
THEY'RE PERPETUATED FOR
HUNDREDS OF YEARS. ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL MANY STUDENTS ARE TAUGHT
ABOUT THE MISSION SYSTEM AND
ITS BENEVOLENCE TOWARDS
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. THESE
WEAPONS INCLUDING NARRATIVE
THAT NATIVE PEOPLE WERE SAVED
BY THE MISSIONS AND THAT THE
RESIDENTS THERE WAS BY CHOICE.
THESE LESSONS ALMOST ALTOGETHER
DENIED THE INJUSTICES. VIOLENCE
ON THE GENOCIDE THAT HEARD AS
PART OF THE CAL. MISSION JUST.
AS WE TO BUILD A MORE JUST AND
EQUITABLE FOR CAL READ WE MY
TELL NOW HIS WARNINGS FOR. WHY
SHOULD WE IGNORE THE BY IN THE
OF THE IMAGE SYSTEM AND FAVOR
OF A ROSE COLORED HISTORY THAT
FAVORS THE CAR CAL IN TO.
REMOVE ONE OF PREDECESSOR
ELEVATES IS ONLY THE BEGINNING
OF TELLING A STORY THAT IS
INCLUSIVE OF ALL VOICES IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK JUST A MOMENT
HOW MANY ICONS OF THE PAST CAN
YOU NAME OFF THE TOP OF YOUR
HEAD. WHO WERE INVOLVED IN THE
COLONIZATION OF CALIFORNIA BY
MEANS OF VIOLENCE AGAINST
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. JOHN SUTTER.
ONE OF BETTER SIR. GET CARDINAL
COME TO MIND AS THEY HAVE BEEN
GRANTED A STATUS OF HISTORICAL
FIGURE DUE TO THEIR PROMINENCE
AND FOUNDING OF CALIFORNIA. YOU
DO NOT THINK OF THE MEANS BY
WHICH THEY PRODUCE THE RESULTS.
ONLY THE MEN THEMSELVES. NOW
TRY TO TAKE THE SAME AMOUNT OF
TIME AND THINK OF CALIFORNIA'S
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE MY ANCESTORS
AMONG THEM. WELL RESPONSIBLE
FOR DEFENDING VARIOUS TRIBAL
CULTURES AND TRADITIONS. DO ANY
COME TO MIND. NOT THAT EVEN IF
THE- R. DAR UNLESS YOU'RE
CALIFORNIA HISTORIAN YOU'LL
STRUGGLE TO NAME ANY INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE BETTER DO THE SIMPLE
FACT THAT IN AMERICA THE
OPPRESSORS HAVE COME TO WRITE
THE NARRATIVE OF THE OPPRESSED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES ROSS IS
AB THREE THIRTY EIGHT TAKE THE
FIRST STEP TOWARDS TELLING
ENACTED HISTORY ON THE PART OF
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE BY REMOVING
ONE OF BETTER SERVICE STATUTE
IT REMOVES A CONSTANT REMINDER
OF THE VIOLENCE PERPETUATED
AGAINST PEOPLE INDIGENOUS TO
THE STATE MY PEOPLE. INSTEAD OF
BEING REMINDED THAT THEIR
ANCESTORS WERE VICTIMS OF THE
VIOLENCE SYSTEM THAT SOUGHT TO
STRIP THEM OF THEIR IDENTITY
AND CULTURE WE CAN'T BEGIN TO
TELL A NARRATIVE OF RESILIENCE
IN THE FACE OF ADVERSITY AND
THAT'S IRONY THAT WILL ALLOW
FOR NATIVE PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
ARE YOU. TO FILL OUT THEIR
IDENTITY AND WHAT TO THE BALLOT%
IN TODAY'S SOCIETY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI. THREE THIRTY
EIGHT. UNCLE MORE. THANK YOU
FOR CHAIRMAN I WANT TO KNOW
THAT WE- INFO OF US THE PICTURE
OF YOSEMITE VALLEY. WHERE CHIEF
TEN IDEA. WAS CHASED INTO THE
MOUNTAINS. BUT AS A PART OF THE
US ARMY. IN THIS ERA. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- CHIEF TRIANGLE-
GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS. IN SOME
MORNING CHAIRMAN BILLION
MEMBERS OF THE- CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES INDEED. I'M SORRY GOOD
MORNING TERMINALLY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM REGION OF
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE SHINGLE
SPRINGS BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS
THE INDIGENOUS HISTORY THE
SACRAMENTO AREA AND ITS PEOPLE
ARE RICH IN HERITAGE CULTURE
AND TRADITION THIS AREA WITH A
VIEW TO THE CENTER CONDITIONAL
ECONOMIC CEREMONIAL AND
POLITICAL POWER JUST AS IT IS
TODAY ARCHIVED ANCESTRY
INCLUDES NISSAN ME WALK AND MY
NEW LINEAGE WHICH DIRECTLY
CONNECTS OUR COMMUNITY TO VERY
DILIGENT AND HOMELAND ALONG.
BETWEEN THE RIVERS IN THIS AREA
ONE OF THE TRIBES PRIMARY
BUILDINGS LIKE FISHING IS
LOCATED AT PRESENT A DISCOVERY
PARK THE LAND WHICH THE CAPITAL
OCCUPIED TODAY IN THE HOME OF
THE SOVEREIGN PEOPLE WHO
ENTERED INTO BY THE EARLY
DECADES OF STATEHOOD IN WHICH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAS
COMPLICIT IN ENACTING VIOLENCE
EXPLOITATION AND ATTEMPTED
DESTRUCTION OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. THESE COMMUNITIES
AND THE MANY TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
WITHIN CALIFORNIA HAVE REMAINED
COMMITTED TO THE STEWARDSHIP OF
THE PLANET SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF TIME. AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO. EIGHT HELPED PROGRAM.
SIR THAN A IT IS VERY MEMORY
THEN MONEY. HAVE SOLD IN NINE
SIX THREE WE WOULD HAVE SHARED
THEIR THE CRITICAL ROLE SLEEP
AND JIM. OF OUR NATIVE.
ANCESTORS IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
WE HAVE THE OUTPOST THE TANAMI
IN DETERMINING HOW WE TELL OUR
STORY. AB THREE THREE EIGHT ONE
OPERATOR TRIBAL NATIONS IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE STATE THE
PLAN CONSTRUCT AND MAINTAIN A
MONUMENT ON THE GROUNDS OF THE
STATE CAPITOL. THIS FIRST
COLLABORATIVE STATUS CRITICAL
TO ENSURE APPROVAL AB THREE
THREE IS A GREAT FIRST STEP IN
A LONG PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT
NATIVE AMERICAN VOICES ARE
HEARD. WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT
TO ERECT A MONUMENT THAT
PROPERLY REPRESENTS OUR
CULTURAL CONTRIBUTION TO THIS
REGION YOU THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST READING AB. THREE
THREE OR IF YOU'LL- THANK YOU
FOR. OF SURE WINNER. WILL NOW
TAKE TO FOR THE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- MISTER SNYDER ARE
YOU WITH US. I AM A TRUST YOU
CAN HEAR ME YES INDEED SIR
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS KEVIN SNYDER
PACIFIC JUSTICE INSTITUTE'S
CENTER FOR PUBLIC POLICY WHERE
I SERVED AS CHIEF COUNSEL. THIS
MORNING I SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO AB THREE THREE EIGHT UNLESS
AMENDED. THE BILL HAS TWO
PRIMARY PARTS IN ONE PART IT
PROPOSES TO ERECT A MONUMENT TO
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PEOPLE OF THE
SACRAMENTO REGION. THERE IS A
PERSON OR PERSONS OF HISTORICAL
SIGNIFICANCE. THROUGH VIRTUE OR
VALOR ARE DESERVING OF
RECOGNITION WE DO NOT OPPOSE
THE STATUTE. WHO DIRECTED IN
THERE ON. WHAT WE DO OPPOSE IS
A STRIKING OF THE LAWCENTER REX
AND MAINTAINS A MONUMENT TO
WHOM THE PARENTS ARE UP THE
APOSTLE OF CALIFORNIA ON THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS. THIS DISDAIN
TOWARDS THINGS HAVING TO DO
WITH CATHOLICISM IS NOT NEW IN
CALIFORNIA. IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
NINE THE ANTI CATHOLIC BLAINE
AMENDMENT WAS ADDED TO THE
STATE CONSTITUTION. THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT. RECENTLY
EXPLAINED THAT BLAINE
AMENDMENTS WERE ADDED TO STATE
CONSTITUTIONS. STILL THE- THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH AND TO
CATHOLICS IN GENERAL. SADLY OF
THE GHOST OF ANTI CATHOLIC
CONTEMPT STILL HAUNTS THE
CAPITOL DOME. CURRENTLY FOR
BILLS THAT TAKE AIM AT
CATHOLICS IN THEIR INSTITUTIONS
ARE WORKING THEIR WAY THROUGH
COMMITTEES AS WE SPEAK. THE
ANTIPATHY TOWARDS THE FAITHFUL
WAS MOST CLEARLY DEMONSTRATED
ON A SUMMER EVENING LAST JULY
FOR IN A NIGHT OF TERROR I'M
GROUP OF MILITANT MARXIST
MARCHED ON THE GROUNDS OF THE
CAPITOL IN VIOLENTLY TOWARD
DOWN THE STATUE. OF FATHER
SERRA WHO WAS HOLDING ACROSS.
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS STOOD BY PASSIVELY.
MOB PROCEEDED TO STOP IT WITH
THEIR FEET. IMAGERY OF THAT
BAND OF THAT EVENT. IT
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE MARXISTS
HAVE NOTHING REDEMPTIVE TO
OFFER THE WORLD THEY STAND. AS
THE RELIGION OF YOUR RELIGION
BE ASSURED THAT THEY ARE NOT
CONTENT TO LET THEIR RAGE ON
OBJECT INANIMATE. IT WILL NOT
BE LONG BEFORE THEY WILL TURN
THEIR TAX ON FLESH AND BLOOD.
THE HISTORICAL RECORD IS CLEAR
IN ALL PLACES AND AT ALL TIMES
WERE MARXIST. CORRECT OUR
JOURNALISM IS A POWER OF THE
BILL MR STEINER. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I SHALL. BUT I WOULD
LIKE LIKE TO RESPOND. THEY HAVE
LEFT THE MARCHES AND THESE ARE
MARKETS JUST TORN DOWN THE
STATUTE MISTER CHAIRMAN I WILL
SPEAK TO THIS. DELTA COMMITTEE
REALLY WANT PUBLIC POLICY. TO
BE SET BY MOB TO INTIMIDATE THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE WOULD NOT
BE. SWAYED TO THE LAW WAS.
MISTER PROFESSIONAL CHAIRMAN
AND MAY I A REMARKS. YOUR YOUR
POINTS ARE NOT. IN OUR RANGE
MISTER CHAIRMAN NO SIR IT IS
NOT PLEASE CONCLUDE. YOUR NOT
DIRECTED YOUR POEMS I WOULD
HAVE POINT ABORTED THIS IS IT
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD ACT AS
A POINT OF ORDER- THAT YOU
ALLOW PERSONS IN OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK. WE INTEND TO ROB POSTED
I DO NOT ADDRESS THE OTHERS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN LET ME CONCLUDE
THAT THE COMMUNITY REALLY WANT
PUBLIC POLICY TO BE SET BY A
MOB TO INTIMIDATE THE
COMMUNITY. LAW SHOULD NOT BE
PASSED TO SWAY TO LAW. IT'S
GOING TO LOG LIVE IN FEAR
PLEASE CLOSE THAT LINE. WE WILL
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. THIS IS
RATIONALIZED THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ONLY.
MODERATOR PLEASE REMIND CALLERS
HOW TO OPEN THEIR LINES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- GET ON THE
PHONE LINES YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI THREE THREE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE AND THEN PLACE IT BACK
INTO THE QUEUE. WELL WILL BEGIN
TODAY WITH A LINE SIXTEEN ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. PLEASE GO AHEAD
MORNING THIS IS. GOOD MORNING
MR YOU ARE NOW TAKING TIME OUT
ON BEHALF OF THE GROUND A BAND
OF MISSION INDIANS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OTHER ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES MODERATOR. S. R. LINE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR MEMBERS FRANK
BELLINO ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
MANUEL BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
AND THE SANTEE NESS BRANDISHES
MESSENGERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY ONE
HOP- WITH RESOLUTE ON BEHALF OF
THE ABOUT MUCH OLD HALLMARK FOR
LAKESIDE AND THE VA HAS TRIED
TO STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE EIGHT. YEAH NINE YOU ARE
OPEN. ONE THIRTY. IF YOU CAN
PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD ON GOAL
I'M GOING TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A FEW ADDITIONAL MINUTES-
HELLO SIR FROM WHAT. AND I'D
LIKE TO READ SOMETHING FROM A
PRESS. OF THE CATHEDRAL THE
BLESSED THANK MALAH. SOLVES ALL
THE YOUR OR PRESERVE. I AM YOUR-
MY NAME IS DAN HANN FROM AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ADDITIONAL
MINUTES READ FROM. WRITTEN BY
FAIRBANKS OF- OF BECAUSE OF
BLOOD BACK. BECAUSE HE BEEN
RESPECTFUL OFFICE FOR THOSE AND
I WOULD LIKE TO. A LITTLE BIT
WRITTEN IN. YOU ARE. YOU MUCH
OKAY WILL GO TO THE LINE- WITH
LINES PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY
SIX YOUR OPEN. THANK THAT IS
YOU. FIVE SIX PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOUR NAME WILL HAVE MY SIX AND
POSITION. SORRY I'M HAVING TO
BE BACK ON THE LINE. I'M I'M
NOT HEARING WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
THERE'S SOME ADDITIONAL PEOPLE
TRYING TO CALL AN- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT. WHAT
ON A LITTLE LINE THIRTY SEVEN.
ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HELLO I AM IN
OPPOSITION OPERATING HISTORY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM WHY
TWENTY NINE. UNDER GOVERNOR ON
BEHALF OF THE MORONGO BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FIND TWENTY FOUR PLEASE THANK
YOU SIR SORRY MR CARE PLEASE GO
AHEAD TWENTY FOUR. SH THE GROUP
PLAN TO GROOM. CALIFORNIA
TRIBES BUSINESSLINE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BY THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRIS GUY ARDO ON
BEHALF OF THE TO ALL ME DOWN
MEANWHILE TRIED CHICKEN RANCH
RANCHERIA IN THE PLACENTA BAND
OF THE LACKEY INDIANS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOU ONE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RED HERRING- MATTER OF
INDIGENOUS ME WALK BABIES ANNA
CATHOLIC I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE THIRTY EIGHT. AND A
FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW OUR
SUPPORT FOR AB THREE THREE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS
HEATHER KELLER AND I OPPOSE
EIGHTY THREE THREE EIGHT. THANK
YOU SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE HAVE A WITNESSES AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. SINAN
WE HAVE A PROMOTION AS BY.
MISTER GIBSON AND THE SECOND WE
HAVE A SECOND SECOND BY MR LEAK
OF. ANY COMMENTS BY WAY OF
CLOTHES MISTER. ALMOST JUST A
ECONOMIST CLOSING- CERTAINLY
SHOWS THE- THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU
HAVE A MENTALITY THAT'S MOVED
FORWARD AND HEARING SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE I'M
CERTAINLY- BLOOD WAS SHED BLOOD
WAS SHED OF THE INDIAN PEOPLE
TO FORCE WERE AT TODAY AND I
BELIEVE IT'S TIME FOR THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO LEARN THE TRUE
HISTORY IN THE IMPACT THAT
THOSE THINGS HAVE HAD ON THE
CALIFORNIA DID PEOPLE AND I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. FROM THE
NORMAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER ROSS COLLEAGUES MISTER
CHAIR. THE AGAIN WE'VE WE'VE
HEARD SOME INTERESTING COMMENTS
FROM OPPOSITION. WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR IT IS SOMEBODY WHO'S
SERVE TIME IN COMBAT WHOSE
ANCESTRY GOES ACROSS. THE
PLANES IN INDIA CALIFORNIA THIS
ISN'T ABOUT RE RACING HISTORY
THIS IS NOT ABOUT CANCEL
CULTURE SAYS VERY SPECIFICALLY.
DESIGNED TO RIP OFF ALL THE
HIDDEN GARBAGE ABOUT OUR
HISTORY. REVEAL THE TRUTH.
WHERE HUMANS OUR HISTORY IS NOT
SUNSHINE AND RAINBOWS. THERE'S
WARS THERE'S BLOOD THERE'S
GENOCIDE THEIR SLAVERY THERE
ARE CHOROS CITIES THAT MANY OF
US IN OUR SUNSHINE AND RAINBOW
BUBBLES. ARE TOO SENSITIVE TO
EVEN WANT TO TALK ABOUT AND
THAT IS THE POINT OF THIS.
FIFTY SHADES THIS IS ACTUALLY
WHAT HAPPENED HERE. WHETHER YOU
LIKE IT OR NOT WHETHER YOU FEEL
THAT IT MIGHT. TARNISH A PAST
PRESTIGIOUS REPUTATION. THE
FACTS ARE THE FACTS THE HISTORY
IS THE HISTORY. AND THAT IS WHY
I'M HONORED AND HUMBLED. TO
PUSH THIS LEGISLATION FOR WITH
MY COLLEAGUES MEMBERS I ASK YOU
FOR YOUR AYE VOTES AGAIN.
BEFORE PROCEDURAL I JUST WANT
TO SEND I THANK YOU. MR RAMA
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
CALIFORNIA WE OFTEN THINK OF
OURSELVES IN THE VANGUARD BUT
TWO YEARS AGO I TRAVELED TO THE
MINNESOTA STATE CAPITOL WHERE
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
SPACE IN THEIR CAPITAL
DEDICATED TO THE SUBJECT MATTER
THE TREATIES MATTER YOU
ACTUALLY FIND ONLINE- THAT
HEADING TREATIES MATTER. AND AS
A KNOWLEDGE MUCH OF A- BAD
HISTORY. WITH THE MINNESOTA
NATIVE PEOPLES AND THERE'S
STATE CAPITOL. AND I THINK OUR-
I PROTECTING APPRECIATE THE
WITNESS THE MOTHERS OF
INDIGENOUS BABIES I THINK WHAT
WE KNOW IS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
REGION WHICH IS THE PEOPLES
THAT WE WILL HONOR BY THIS
MONUMENT. WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT
LIVED FOR THOUSANDS OF YEARS.
SUCCESSFULLY IN A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE WORLD IN
WHICH THEY LIVE I TAKE DOES
THAT BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
WHICH IS INDUCED BY. OUR
ACTIVITIES. THEY LIVED IN
BALANCE WITH THEIR- ENVIRONMENT
AND THEY WANT THE SAME THING
FOR THEIR CHILDREN THE WAY OF
WELL BEING UPBRINGING HOPE FOR
THE FUTURE STABILITY IN THEIR
LIVES THESE ARE THE SAME THINGS
THAT WE ASPIRE TO IS LAWMAKERS
TO UNDERTAKE ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. SO I
THINK THIS IS ACTUALLY A
POWERFUL REMINDER. THAT AS MR
MATHESON SAID WE ARE PEOPLE. WE
HAVE THE GOOD AND THE BAD. I
THINK HERE IN SACRAMENTO THERE
IS A LONG HISTORY OF PEOPLE
DEVOTED TO THE WELL BEING OF
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
SUCCESSORS. AND WE ARE JUST THE
LATEST EXPRESSION OF THAT IN
THIS BUILDING. AND I ACTUALLY
FEEL I TAKE SOME STRENGTH FROM
THE HERITAGE TO DISMANTLE
SALVAGE WHAT THAT- MISTER
CORPORATE WILL TAKE THE ROLE.
ON AB THREE THREE EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM BENNETT FLORA GIPSON
PROBABLY. GIPSON HI LEE. WE AYE
LEVINE HI LEVINE AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS HI MATHIS IRA MOST ALL
RIGHT RAMOS HI RUBIO. RUBIO IV
APPROVED LAW- HI. THAT MOTIONS-
THAT MEASURE HAS PASSED AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS RULES
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OKAY THAT OF A-
FROM.